[Music]
welcome to AI the future of us a podcast
Style video series that explores the way
AI is shaping our future and how we can
prepare for the changes that lie ahead
I'm your host Chloe Condon and today
we're joined by farat teckener who is a
senior staff product manager here at
Google focusing on data and AI products
thank you for being here today hi Chloe
thanks for having me
thanks for talking to us so I would love
to know about your background and your
expertise could you tell us a little bit
about how you found yourself in this
field of data and AI
that's an interesting question uh so I
grew up on machine learning and store
Computing I you know during my PhD I
built my own cluster of you know
hypervous Computing environments because
there are no such things like cloud and
stuff to simulate reinforcement learning
and in the process you know through the
years in my time in Academia as a
postdoc and a senior academic I became
good at data and moved into analytics
and moved into industry as well in the
process I work with some of the largest
organizations on architecting their data
and AI environments within the past 20
years so I sit on the fence trying to
bridge the gap between data and Ai and
found ourselves within this world or
Jenai at the moment
and you really can't have one without
the other right so it's really
interesting that you've now found
yourself in this role that combines the
two so how did how did you become
interested in Ai and and what what made
it so fascinating to you
so throughout my studies I I really had
an interest uh when I was in university
uh but then you're doing my PhD uh the
problem that I had to solve was looking
for a the optimal routing algorithm then
one day I went and this was listening
how the biologists in the department
were talking around ants and I heard
that they always find the shortest path
from there talking about little like
picnic blanket ants right yes absolutely
and they're fascinating you know
creatures right it is it is it was
interesting to see and read all these
articles in nature and everything as
well because they they always somehow
find this uh you know path from the food
source and today Nas the shortest path
they released some chemicals on the way
and this chemicals in time evaporates as
well and more on goes through the the
shortest path all the time and this acts
like a reinforcement learning when it is
applied in in you know machine learning
in a sense someone applied it I have
taken I applied different ways and you
know weaves into that as well and that
afterwards I you know I moved into Super
Computing because that's what I was
doing uh within uh within my research as
well and work at the initial Center for
uh super Computing and text mining here
in Manchester UK and looking at the core
ml models uh throughout my academic work
and focusing on the very large data
problems as well and I ended continue
after I moved into industry I continued
supervising PhD students and such and
focusing things like forecasting stock
prices looking to see how we can
optimize and so on so my career really
built around data and AI for the past 25
years in Academia and Industry
and I love that it all started with ants
right as the the in they're just walking
around all around us not knowing that
they've inspired someone who works at
Google who works on AI and ml stuff
shout out to ants
absolutely so could you share some of
your key data and AI developments that
you've witnessed during your career I'm
sure you've seen a lot of interesting
data and and come to a lot of
interesting conclusions from that data
I'd love to learn more about what you've
seen and learned
yes that's an interesting question so
for me the the way that it happens is
that the AI and data problems always
have three dimensions first is the the
storage so the data portion of it the
second is the algorithms and the third
part is the computational power that you
use it is like a triangle and we are
saying the data and super Computing are
really coming together so the first one
is the rise of Big Data really coming
from Google funnily enough uh Wireless I
was doing my research as well and having
the availability of large data sets has
been essential for development of the ml
algorithms as well these data sets are
low ml algorithms to learn from lot
wider range of examples which make them
more accurate and robots so the Big Data
area filled by Hadoop really enabled
that we we stored a lot more data and
then that led to the development of new
algorithms as well the ml researchers
have developed wide range or algorithms
within the recent years uh you know
starting from Deep learning algorithms
where they have enabled the computers to
achieve uh how the the human's brain
work really when you look at the neural
networks but achieving superhuman
performance and you know exploiting that
capability with huge amounts of
computational power on tasks such as
image recognition and natural language
processing and we know that this is
applied to many disciplines and the
increase using computing power has also
been major factor in progress or ml as
well because if wants to increase the
amount of data that you are feeding into
these algorithms effectively what's
happening is you are increa you are
making your problem size bigger as well
and more powerful computers can now
train ml models on larger data sets
which also leads to more complex
algorithms so in your opinion what are
the main challenges that firms face on
generating value from data and AI
applications
the the power of big data and machine
learning is undeniable they are here
they have the potential to revolutionize
the businesses and how we solve very
large problems uh they can be used to
create compelling customer experiences
or they can be used to really solve very
challenging problems like how we find
interaction between proteins and such as
well
data on the other hand is the field for
AI ml algorithms would only work well
with the data that they are fed into
that means that you need to have the
high quality data in order to get the
most out of your machine learning
algorithms on Modern the problem is that
the lotto organizations have been
creating these data mountains or data
oceans
whereby the storage is very cheap and
they've been bringing all of these data
sources together and it is really
becoming very hard for them to analyze
and use this data in a meaningful way to
get the value out of it the cloud really
comes into play here because our laws
organization to bring usually siled
applications closer to each other it is
improving the way that we have access to
the systems and it is helping a lot of
personas to come and access to the
systems as well however you still need
to find a way to process annotate enrich
and expand your data in order to make it
more meaningful really genetic AI is the
really a new type O AI that can help you
to automate summarize and generate more
meaningful data particularly from
unstructured data like the text and such
as well
it is important because if you can
consume this data in in an automated way
imagine that all of the libraries and
everything that you have and you'll be
able to get most out of it however as I
mentioned you really need to have high
quality data in order to get the most
out of it as well the cloud as I said
brings your data together and make it
more accessible but generator AI is kind
of the future of the data science it can
help you to really summarize and
automate the the processes that you are
dealing with and also generate data as
well it is it it and it really comes to
a choice between whether you should be
building your Solutions or whether you
should be you know using a pre-built
Solutions as well and I'm not going to
get into the details of the the
foundational models and llms and such
there are a lot of talks around that but
it's really around whether you should be
using one or you know building yourself
can you expand a little bit more on the
decision around building and buying and
how organizations can address this you
know moving forward with data Mountains
for example
yes the choice between you know building
and buying is that three of them
actually right so you either build
something or you you know uh use
existing one but there's also a middle
uh middle part as well which we call
automl type Solutions or bigquery ml
type Solutions here that we have in
Google as well they're building your own
ml models can be that expensive and time
consuming on one end right but it gives
you the most control over the process
and allows you to customize your models
to your specific needs on the other hand
buying ml models can be much faster and
more cost office efficient option
however you may be limited to the
features and functionality of the models
that are available the best option for
you will depend on your specific needs
budget if you have resources to build
your own models it might be the best
option for you but it also depends what
type of organization you are as well not
all the organizations have a lot of
folks who will be able to do that but
let me get a little bit more detail into
it and expand a little bit more as well
it it should start with identifying the
right AI use case for you know it is
essential for Success really you need to
have a clear understanding of your
business scores and the problems that
you are trying to solve and once you
know what you are trying to achieve you
can start identifying the AI
technologies that can help you to get
that it is important to think big but
also start small as well don't try to
build a complex AI system from the
ground up instead start with a simple
use case that you get quickly Implement
and test you understand what is
available there and if your teams are
not
not familiar with some of the processes
it helps you to resolve that at the
beginning right and as I mentioned there
are three main you know levels that you
can do this one of them is buying that
you can use a apis you can use
pre-trained API models that are
available right AI models that are
available as apis and the easiest way to
get started with AI is really this way
but it offers the list flexibility for
you on the flip side and what we call
automl is that it gives you the ability
to use the tools to automate the process
of building training AI models this is a
good option if you have some technical
expertise but you don't want to spend a
lot of time on model development and
there's also the you know custom models
as you said that you can build your own
AI models from scratch and this doesn't
only apply to the generative AI
Solutions or llms it applies generally
for all the ml problems out there the
key is though right it is an
optimization problem you need to decide
and whether your teams have the skill
set usually what we see and what I see
from the organizations have been doing
you start experimenting from one the
easiest one you move into the other and
then once you develop that expertise
understand which ones are giving you the
most return for your Investments then
you can invest more time on building
custom models as well
and what are some of your tips for
organizations who are looking to start
their data and AI Journeys where should
they have their head at when they're
beginning this journey
yeah that's a that's an interesting uh
question the best way to choose the
right level AI uh development is really
look into your specific needs and goals
if you need a quick and easy solution as
I mentioned API based AI solution is a
good one right but I I would I would
focus on the business problem first what
are the specific problems you are trying
to solve you shouldn't be doing it just
for the sake of doing that look for the
opportunities automate tasks because
these type of uh AI problems your
applications can really help you to
automate any repetitive or time
consuming tasks particularly from the
generative AI side of things but
identifying bright data sources we said
that data is filled for AI as well and
what do you need to train the date you
know your ml algorithms with what are
the data sources are the most important
ones and consider the costlow
implementation how much time that you
are going to invest from the Personnel
or and how much resources that you are
going to need if you are training things
as well and also it is important what
type of organization are you not
everyone should focus on creating models
but you should be able to use them as
well right and what type of organization
that you are is not the entire
organization that you are in but it
might be the team that you are in as
well you might be working with other
teams within your organization who might
be developing the models and you might
be just calling the apis available
through them as well so you mentioned
generative Ai and do you have some
examples of how gen AI is currently
being used effectively in the data
ecosystem
yes that's an interesting question so uh
it is effectively top of mind for
everyone to really look into
democratizing analytics because look
everyone is really looking for assistive
uh development capabilities so
effectively what happens is that
everyone comes you provide some natural
language and then with that nature
language it helps you to write the code
so it gives you a kick start right so it
also helps you to automate chord
generation as I mentioned but it goes
further it can help you debugging things
and even help you to do performance
optimization and such as well it is
really making
the ml side of things and data more
accessible to everyone within your
organization including the non-technical
users right so traditionally what this
is that you need to write SQL queries or
python code or some Java code or spark
code as well you can generate some of
that and you can get to the insights
very quickly but it is really important
at the same time to have human
intervention you know for these classes
as well the the goal is to make it
easier for everyone to develop better
quality code regardless of their skill
set but it is not really aiming to
replace people doing that and what I say
is that you know people who have the
better backgrounds will be able to fear
better so that is the assistive support
right there's also uh the huge uh to
focus on tapping into the potential of
the unstructured data particularly using
llms and everyone is looking to extract
value from unstructured data we are
really it is like we are sitting on a
gold mine that we haven't really tapped
into yet right because there's so much
unstructured data whether as I mentioned
in text or images and such and we can
get more value and we we can bring this
near to the structured data that we have
and enrich it with the unstructured data
for better insights with our
interactions either by customers or the
problems that we are trying to solve and
another way another the one that we are
saying is doing more Automation and as
well as a generation right customers are
looking for ways to automate repetitive
tasks but also generate content as well
such as emails and documents or even
websites you might have your data in
your data warehouse and you buy with a
click or a button by joining that with
your structured data you might be
generating emails or you might be
generating website content and such so
it is really bringing these diverse
environments together and
augmented augmenting with unstructured
data is what everyone is looking for
I'm pretty sure that all of the data
that I've done on social media pointed
me towards buying this shirt because I
like Google branded things so um shout
out shout out to data for suggesting all
of these things that I end up buying in
my feed
um so you mentioned a little bit about
you know democratizing analytics and and
really you you mentioned giving
non-technical people access to this data
this seems really like a game changer
for everyone to be able to use AI could
you talk a little bit you know more
about you know Automation and generation
and and how people are are using these
products
so some of the things that I'm saying is
organizations uh the unstructured data
gives you for example you might look in
some social data right social media data
whether if you have a brand or if you're
a product uh as as like the one that you
might have just uh purchased right you
might go and put your feelings whether
you like it or whether you didn't like
it into a social media platform and you
can capture this and you can look into
the sentiment of that person for example
using things like llms right you can
then go and classify this whether Chloe
was happy with this purchase or she was
she wasn't happy with that purchase and
then you can take next action and you
might fire off an email or something
like that right and that's why I get so
many things about theme parks so
all the data is saying that I'm a very
happy person who loves theme parks is
what I'm getting from that
and and that seems like a really top
concern for people at the moment is how
do we make sure that AI is used for good
and how how do we know that you know
here at Google we of course have all our
AI principles but can we dive a little
bit more into AI being used for good
I think the key is taking a
human-centric approach
understanding the way that users will
interact with the service that you are
building and assisting them looking at
multiple metrics will help you to
understand your model better as well as
thinking about what are some of the
metrics that you might want to you know
monitor in production for example when
we have an AI system in production how
are we going to measure performance or
some of the issues that might arrive
also this is an iterative process you
should be testing you should be learning
and you should be improving and going
back into testing it is like a
never-ending process really because the
way that we are interacting with the
systems is changing all the time you
might have heard I I mentioned already
the reinforcement learning the little
ants always learns the way that they
operate within their ecosystem as well
but we human beings also as we as we
interact with the systems can provide
feedback back to the to these algorithms
and the systems that we are using and we
should bring that in as well but as we
said data is key for everything
understand your data that is the core
for the system that you have what are
the feature used whether this is
something generated by a team that you
know that you are involved in or by a
third party that can be within your
organization or outside of your
organization you might not know what the
data that goes into it it's really again
coming back and it is all about data it
is a high quality data that you bring in
that you understand whether it has been
drive from and you understand the
qualities of the data that really helps
us to be more human-centric as well
and speaking of data
professionals so how should data
professionals think about what Ai and
data and all of these things are doing
to their day-to-day and their roles
mostly the practitioners really spend
most of their time doing repetitive
tasks and we have many personas dealing
with different parts of the challenge
right so you might have data Engineers
creating pipelines data analysts
analyzing the data and data scientists
you know looking for insights yet
everyone in the organization is part of
this process as well there has been you
know a lot of
talks around the data mesh and such
trying to solve the challenges and
Bridging the organ bringing the
organizational sites together but as we
said the goal is we are going to be
seeing more and more of this Persona
overlapping on the things that they're
doing I mentioned that data Engineers
are creating pipelines and data analysts
are analyzing the data scientists are
doing the ml models well with the
assistive capabilities we'll be seeing
some of the data Engineers perhaps
topping into the qualities of the ml
models and they might go and say I've
just created this data I've just joined
this this to data sources but I would
like to classify this you run an ml
model and maybe directly from the data
warehouse that you are working from and
you classify the data now you are doing
the core ml tasks as well as a data
engineer traditionally that's what
that's not something that you would do
and we'll be seeing more and more of
this happening but this doesn't mean
that the these professions and you know
uh the personas are going to go away I
feel like they are going to be here they
are going to be powered by these tools
but they are going to be a lot more
productive they'll spend more time on
what is important rather than creating
these repetitive tasks
and what do you believe is the most
exciting potential application of AI
that that we've yet to see what what do
you think's out there that we've yet to
see in this world of exciting new
possibilities
I'll follow on from you know uh what I
said just earlier it is democratization
of data and AI right so for example uh
I'm a I'm a c programmer by uh trade
I've been right I've written a lot of C
code I I know how to write SQL but there
are lots of people who writes better SQL
than I do right and I I openly say this
and what what I tend to do these days is
I go and generate my SQL first right or
if I write some SQL I go and check
whether there's a better version of the
sequel so it is assisting me it is
helping me to have that start uh
starting point as well or I might not
find that function on top of mind when I
write some SQL and I can go and generate
that but at the same time working with
unstructured data we are also making
data more accessible for everyone such
as tax it wasn't as always
straightforward as it was today to
process Text data for example if you
want to create an analyze Zone over
customer satisfaction you would have
rarely used text review using machine
learning right for symptom allies as I
mentioned before for the social data or
there would be other Solutions such as
you might have seen that there has been
some work have been done on the medical
data which gives you more prescriptive
answers you might go and search what are
the symptoms for XYZ illness right and
you can get from a very specific models
that are trained on very specific Corpus
I'm tuned on very specific ways as well
and with llms this is what has changed
it is really making data more accessible
to The Wider community
what advice would you give to
individuals and businesses looking to
prepare for a future in which AI plays
an even more significant role than it
does now
the foundations are still the key you
still need the core domain knowledge to
be able to leverage the most out of the
capabilities these systems provide in
order to get the value out of it you
should be able to understand the
feedback that you get from these systems
this will be trickier to analyze so you
should be able to have that core domain
expertise as well as the technical
expertise in computer systems and if you
have the foundations you'll be able to
really successful on creating the right
projects but also your creativity is
going to play a significant role in my
opinion because it is going to make it
you know make you more creative you'll
not be spending more time on repetitive
tasks because you are automating that
you'll be able to focus on uh what are
the core capabilities and using llms in
your day-to-day work you'll be able to
really get that uh creative person out
of yourself it will allow
organizations to come up with more
innovative solutions as a result it will
give you more tool sets to display your
creativity as well
and as we look ahead to the future of
data and AI what would be your last
words before we finish this off
and you might have you know for that
food that I have been saying data data
data right it is all about data yes I
understand everyone wants to hear the
you know ml algorithms and everything
yes that's what my background as well
but I spend most of my time 80 of my
time that preparing the data for the ml
algorithms that I fit into it's also
important to focus on the use cases it
is very important to identify what is
the right solution and what is The Right
Use case for the uh for the challenges
that you are asked to deal with right
you should be able to identify what are
the right approaches uh from the AI and
ml side as well not all the algorithms
work you know well for example the
the llms are good at telling you and
giving you concise answers from the text
letter that they have also we have ml
models that gives you how the weather
might be tomorrow right but they'll not
be able to tell you for example Chloe if
I tell you that tomorrow it might be
raining where you are based but I cannot
tell you whether you would be taking
your umbrella with you when you go out
or not right that's the decision that
sits with you and ml algorithms will not
be able to help you on that and also we
need to realize that every organization
every team that we operate is very
different they'll have different
capabilities and they'll have different
skills it is therefore important to
treat and find what are the rights ways
of getting to the point that we want to
get but underneath all of these having
an integrated data and AI ecosystem is
called for Success because if you are
spending your time all the time or your
time always finding how much memory that
I need how many CPUs that I would need
you'll not be able to get that or do I
need access rights to the system I'm
working on the system you will not be
able to get that you need an integrated
data and AI ecosystem really for success
thank you so much for joining us today
ferrat it's been so insightful to hear
your thoughts on the impact of effective
use of AI we covered a lot of topics
today and I'm so excited for people to
learn more and we look forward to seeing
how AI will continue to shape the world
around us and hope that our viewers will
be inspired to embrace its potential and
opportunities thanks for having me I
really enjoyed this shot
foreign